PROFESSOR: Let's do adiabatic
evolution really now.
Evolution.
We're going to say
lots of things,
but the take away message is
going to be the following.
We're going to get maybe
even confused as we do this,
but the take away
message is the following.
You sort of begin in
some quantum state,
and you're going to remain
in that quantum state
as it changes.
All the states are
going to be changing.
The quantum states are going
to be changing in time.
And you're going to remain
on that quantum state
with an extra
phase that is going
to have important information.
That's basically all
that's going to happen.
There's a lot of subtleties
in what I've said,
and we have to unmask
those subtleties.
But you're going to remain
in that state up to a phase.
That phase is going to be
called something, Berry's phase.
And there's a
dynamical phase as well
that is simple and
familiar, but Berry's phase
is a little less familiar.
So you're going to get the
same state up to a phase.
You're not going to jump states.
After we'll do that, we'll do
Landau-Zener transitions, which
are an example
where you can jump,
and you will calculate
and determine
how big is the
suppression to jump,
and so it will
reinforce [INAUDIBLE]..
So let me begin with this thing.
Suppose you have an H of t.
And now, you come
across this states that
satisfy the following thing.
H of t, psi of t, is
equal to E of t psi of t.
If this equation doesn't
look to you totally strange,
you're not looking hard enough.
It is a very strange equation.
It looks familiar.
It looks like everything
we've always been writing,
but it's not.
Look what this is saying.
Suppose you look at the
Hamiltonian at time 0.
Then the state at time
0 would be an eigenstate
of the Hamiltonian at
time 0 with some energy
at time 0 and some state here.
So this is what's called an
instantaneous eigenstate.
It's an eigenstate
at every time.
It's almost as if you find the
eigenstate at time equals 0.
You find the eigenstate
at time equals epsilon.
at time equal 2 epsilon.
Each time, and
you piece together
a time dependent
energy eigenstate
with a time dependent energy.
We never did that.
Our energy eigenstates
were all time independent.
So what kind of
crazy thing is this?
Well, it has some intuition.
You know how to do it.
You know the Hamiltonian at
every time, and at any time,
you can find eigenstates.
Now, you've solved
at time equals 0,
and you solve it at
time equals epsilon,
and at time equals
epsilon, you're
going to have
different eigenstate.
But at time equals
0, you're going
to have lots of eigenstate.
At time equals
epsilon, you're going
to have lots of eigenstate,
but presumably, things
are not changing too fast.
You will know which
one goes with which.
Like at time equals 0, I
get all these eigenstate,
and at time equal epsilon,
I'll get this eigenstates,
and presumably, you think,
well, maybe I can join them.
I'm not going to go this to
that, because it's a big jump,
and you can track them.
So this you could
find many of those.
These are called are
instantaneous eigenstates.
They are a little
strange, because suppose
you find those eigenstates,
this is so far so good,
but maybe this goes like that,
and this crosses that one.
Oh-- then how do you know
which one, should you go here,
or should you go here, which
one is your eigenstate?
So let's just hope
that doesn't happen.
It's going to be very
difficult if it happens.
Moreover, there's going to be--
these states are
not all that unique.
I could multiply
this Hamiltonian,
this state by phase e
to the i chi of t here,
and a time dependent phase,
the Hamiltonian wouldn't care.
It would cancel.
So these states are
just not very unique.
Now, the more important thing
I want to say about them,
they are the beginning
of our explicit analysis,
is that do these psi's of t's
solve the Schrodinger equation?
Are these the solutions of
the Schrodinger equation?
We've found the
instantaneous eigen-- so
are these solutions of
the Schrodinger equation?
Is that what it means to solve
I hear no.
That's true.
Not at all.
These are auxiliary states.
They don't quite solve
the Schrodinger equation.
And we'll try to use them to
solve the Schrodinger equation.
That's what we're
going to try to do.
So let's try to appreciate that.
This are psi's of t.
Now, my notation is going
to be a little delicate.
Here is your
Schrodinger equation.
The only difference
is that thing here.
Now, we're suppressing
all spatial dependent.
The Hamiltonian might
depend on x and p,
and the wave function may
depend on x and p, [INAUDIBLE]
x and other things,
and spin, other things
will just suppress them.
So this is the equation
we're trying to solve.
This is the real equation
that we're trying to solve.
And if you just
plug the top thing
and try to see if that
solves that equation,
you will find it
very quickly doesn't
solve this equation at all.
The left hand side,
if you plugged
in there will appear a psi dot.
If you thought psi of
t solves this equation,
you will have a psi dot, and
here you will have an energy,
and what is supposed to be
a psi dot, it's not obvious.
It just doesn't solve it.
So on the other hand,
we can try to inspire
ourselves to solve it this way.
You will write in ansatz.
So we'll put a psi of t.
We'll try to build our
solution by putting
maybe the kind of
thing that you usually
put for an energy eigenstate.
When you have an
energy eigenstate,
you would put an e to
the minus i et over h bar
to solve the
Schrodinger equation.
So let's do the same thing here.
Let's put on top of the psi
of t an e to the minus i
over h bar energy.
But the energy depends on time
so, actually, the clever thing
to try to put here
is an integral
of the energy of time,
dt prime, up to t,
because the main
thing of that phase
is that its derivative
should be the energy.
So that should help.
So maybe this is
almost a solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
But that may not be the case,
so let's put just in case
here, a c of t that
maybe we will need it
in order to solve the
Schrodinger equation.
So our idea is OK, we're
given those instantaneous
eigenstates, and let's
use them to get a solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
Of course, if we
found that this is
a solution of the
Schrodinger equation,
we would have found that
with some modification,
the instantaneous eigenstates
produce solutions.
And that would be very nice.
We will find,
essentially, that that's
true in the adiabatic
approximation.
So let's do this calculation,
which is important and gives us
our first sight of
the adiabatic result.
So here is the psi of t.
Now let's substitute into
the Schrodinger equation.
So I have the left
hand side is left
hand side is i h bar dt
t of this psi would be--
first, I differentiate the c.
So c dot e to the minus i
h bar integral to t E dt
prime, psi of t.
Plus-- now I differentiate
this exponent, i h bar.
So I'm sorry, I
have i h bar here.
When I differentiate
this exponent,
the i's cancel with the signs.
The h bar cancels.
I get an E evaluated at t.
I'm differentiating with
respect to time here.
So I get here, nicely, E of
t times the [? Hall ?] wave
function again, psi of t.
And then, finally, I get
plus i h bar c of t--
i h bar c of t times the
exponent and the time
derivative of psi minus i
over h bar t E dt prime times
psi of t dot.
So that is the dot of the state.
You can differentiate the state,
means evaluating the state at t
plus epsilon minus [INAUDIBLE]
t divide by epsilon.
So we'll write it as
this psi dot in there.
So what do we get here.
Let's see the right hand
side, right hand side
is H on the state
and H on the state
comes here and ignores this
factor, ignores these factors.
Our time dependent factors
come here and produces
a factor of e of t.
So H on psi of t is just
E of t times psi of t.
So what happens, left hand
side equal to right hand side.
This term cancels with this.
This is nice.
That's what the energy and
the instantaneous states
should have done.
But we're left with two
more terms that then cancel.
These two terms.
c dot is related to psi dot.
So indeed, there's no obvious
way of generating a solution,
because there is a term in the
Schrodinger equation with psi
dot that must be
canceled or properly
taken care of by c dot here.
So what is the
equation that we have?
We have this first term, but
the second term should be 0.
So it's a simple equation.
You can cancel
everything basically.
The phase can be canceled
the i H can be canceled.
So we get c dot of
t times psi of t
is equal to minus c
of t times psi dot.
That's what we have to solve.
OK, we have to solve that.
Let's see how it goes.
Let's see.
OK, let's try to
solve this equation
by sandwiching psi of t,
one of those instantaneous
eigenstates from the left.
So what do we get here?
Well, this is just a function.
It just doesn't care,
and psi is supposed
to be normalized state.
Maybe I should have said, these
are instantaneous eigenstates,
and psi of t, psi
of t is equal to 1.
They're normalized at
every instant of time.
That should not be
difficult to implement.
So we get here c dot
of t equals minus c
of t psi of t, psi dot of t.
That's the kind of
differential equation.
It just doesn't look
that bad at all.
In fact, it's one of those
differential equations
you can solve.
And the answer is c
of t is equal to e
to the minus 0 to t psi of t
prime, psi dot of t prime, dt
prime.
And that's the answer.
In fact, take the
derivative, and you
see this is an
equation of the form f
dot is equal to a
function of time times f.
This is solved by integration.
That's what it is.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is the base?
PROFESSOR: We will see that.
That's my next point.
We have here a c of t,
and we have an integral.
Now, it looks decaying,
but it's actually a phase.
Let's see that.
So I want to understand
what is psi, psi dot.
I claim that this quantity,
in fact, is purely imaginary.
Let's see why.
What is this thing?
This is an overlap intuitively
over x of psi of x and t star
d dt of psi of x and t.
And this, this is
a dv x integral.
It's a vector
integral in general.
I don't have to put
arrows, I think.
I have d dt of psi star psi
minus the psi star dt psi.
This is just a little bit
like pre-integration by parts,
is just saying a db
is d of ab minus b da.
That's an identity.
Now the first term, it's a d
dt of an integral, so over x.
So the d dt goes out.
And you have the integral
over x of psi star psi.
That's the first star.
And the second term
is minus the integral
of dx of d psi star psi.
But I will write it as psi d
dt of psi star here with a star
there.
Lots of stars.
Sorry.
Can you see that?
The first term they
took out the derivative.
The second term,
the sign is out,
and you have the
psi star times psi,
but that's a complex conjugate
of that other integral.
The integral over space is 1.
So this is 0.
So this is equal to
minus psi, psi dot star.
That thing in
parentheses is psi dot.
So what did you show that
this complex number is minus
its complex conjugate?
So that thing is indeed a
purely imaginary number.
OK, so we're almost there.
So let's write this nicely.
What did we find?
Psi of t is equal--
the psi of t, it's c
of t times this phase.
So I'll put first
this phase here.
I'll call it c of 0 here.
I ignored it before, but
I could have put it here.
I don't have to put it--
there's no need for it.
e to the minus i over h bar, the
integral from 0 to t of e of t
prime dt prime.
That's it.
And then, I have this
factor, this c of t
that I have to include.
So let's put that
phase here, too.
It's e to the-- this minus is
coming in to replace it by an i
with another i in here.
Why would you do that?
Well, it's good
notation actually,
psi, psi dot of t
prime, dt prime.
And all that multiplying,
the instantaneous eigenstate.
You see, this thing,
this i in front
is telling you that if
you're using good notation,
that this quantity
is a pure phase.
And indeed, it's a pure phase,
because this thing is already
known to be imaginary.
So with an i, this is
real, and with this i,
this is a pure phase.
So it's just notation.
So here it is.
We did it.
But I must say, we made
a very serious mistake,
and I want to know if you can
identify where was our mistake.
Let's give a little
turn to somebody else
to see where is the mistake,
and then you have your go.
Anybody wants to say
what is the mistake.
the mistake is so serious
that I don't really
have the right to--
look, if I didn't
make a mistake,
I've done something
unbelievable.
I found the solution of
the Schrodinger equation
using the instantaneous
eigenstate.
I took the instantaneous
eigenstate,
and now I've built the solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
That is an
unbelievable statement.
It would show that
you will remain
in the instantaneous
eigenstate forever,
and I never used slow variation.
So this would be an exact state.
This better be wrong.
This cannot be right.
It cannot be that you always
remain the same eigenstate.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
There's going to be a
problem with that equation.
We did a little mistake here.
Well, we didn't do a mistake,
but we didn't do our full job.
Remember in
perturbation theory when
you had to find the first order
of correction to the state,
you put from the left a state
in the original subspace.
You put the state
outside sub space.
Here we dotted with psi of t.
But we have to dot with every
state in the Hilbert space
to make sure we have a solution.
If you have a vector equation,
you cannot just dot with
something and say,
OK, I solved it.
You might have solved the x
component of the equation.
So we really did not
solve this equation.
So we made a serious
mistake in doing this.
But the good thing is that
this is not a bad mistake
in the sense of learning.
The only thing I
have to say here
is that this is
approximately true
when the changes are the
adiabatic, if the change is
adiabatic.
And that is what
we're going to justify
next time with another
detailed analysis of this.
So we did a good effort
to find an exact solution
of the Schrodinger
equation, and we came close.
And this is a pretty
good approximation.
This is the statement of
the adiabatic theorem.
You pretty much follow the
instantaneous eigenstate up
to a dynamical phase
and up to a Berry phase.
But this is not an exact
solution of the Schrodinger
equation, and in
some cases, there
will be transitions
between those instantaneous
eigenstates.